in Schönau im Schwarzwald führt mitten
über den Schulhof des örtlichen
Gymnasiums diese Straße ihren Pausenhof
müssen sich die Kinder mit
vorbeifahrenden Autos Teilen geschützt
werden sie notdürftig durch einen
Bauzaun die Schüler fühlen sich
eingespart
man würde gerne dass man sich frei
bewegen kann und dieser Zaun nicht immer
im Weg steht natürlich geht der Zaun so
weit dass er uns schützt vor den Autos
aber das dann die Autos durchfahren
dürfen und wir eben hinter dem Zaun sind
das ist eben das was uns daran stört und
hat halt eben nicht den Platz den man
gerne hätte und es ist schon nicht so
leicht hier zu Spielen
2006 wird das Gymnasium vergrößert nun
aber ist der Pausenhof zu klein der
Rathausplatz gegenüber wird kurze Hand
zum zusätzlichen Schulhof erklärt
eigentlich ist die Erweiterung eine
feine Sache wenn jetzt die Talstraße
nicht mitten durchführen würde
ein unmöglicher Zustand aber seit 17
Jahren findet die Stadt keine Lösung
zuletzt lehnte der Stadtrat im Frühjahr
eine Sperrung während der Schulzeit ab
statt die Autos zu verbannen werden nun
die Kinder hinter einem Bauzaun
eingesperrt an den Autos vorbei geht es
hier durch von einem Schulhof Teil zum
anderen der Schuldirektor fordert die
Autos müssen weg
die Lösung liegt auch für uns auf der
Hand das eben hier der Pausenbereich der
durch die Straße unterteilt wird dass
der einfach zu einem geschlossenen
Pausenbereich wird in der Zeit in der
wir Schule haben aber der Stadtrat will
keine Sperrung absurd denn es gibt hier
zwei Straßen und dort zwei Straßen auf
den man ganz bequem ins Stadtzentrum
fahren kann die über den Schulhof
braucht eigentlich niemand die meisten
Ratsmitglieder aber lassen das nicht
gelten ah es hat natürlich verschiedene
Hintergründe da sind Ängste dabei man
kommt nicht mehr zu den Geschäften ich
selber sagt man kommt zum Geschäft
damals viele Straßen jetzt gibt Essen
Ängste da
gewohntes aufzugeben da steht man als
Bürgermeister einigermaßen machtlos da
aber dann muss man das anerkennen was in
demokratischen Prozess entschieden
worden ist die Eltern haben die Nase
voll wollen den Beschluss des Stadtrates
aufheben lassen sie haben Unterschriften
für ein Bürgerentscheid gesammelt
eigentlich gesperrt wieso im Zoo also
das findet jetzt keiner gerade cool
alle für eine andere Lösung wir sind
dafür ein Pausenzeiten oder zu Vormittag
haben gesperrt wird sie ist die Schüler
diesen Platz nutzen können und der Zaun
einfach überflüssig wird in Schönau
Stimmen am 15 Oktober nun die Bürger
darüber ab ob die Straße für den
Autoverkehr vormittags gesperrt wird zur
Sicherheit und zum Wohle der Kinder